than those in quantum chemistry may experience the same impediments if the Hamiltonians have too many non-commuting
terms. The Kryof method is most useful where the Hamiltonian can be partitioned into relatively few commuting poly
groupoups and where H is easy to implement in troder circuits. Both of these conditions are satisfied. For
example, for many lattice models of interest in physics, KQD is especially useful if very little is known about the
ground state. This stems from its inherent convergence guarantees and its applicability in scenarios where
alternative methods are untenable due to insufficient ground state knowledge.
While KQD is a powerful tool, the protocol's time-consuming aspects, particularly the estimation of each
element of the projected Hamiltonian and the overlap of Kryof states, represent opportunities for an improvement. An
alternative approach involves approximating the kryoff state using troder circuits, then sampling the
approximated state to obtain a projection onto the computational basis and then projecting h onto the subspace
spanned by these computational basis states.
In cases where it is applicable, this methodology known as sampling based kryof quantum diagonalization SKQD
potentially offers significant reductions in time and resource requirements compared to traditional KQD.
The integration of Kryof subspace techniques with sampling methods in SKQD represents an exciting frontier in
quantum algorithms.